hey
oh ok again a trail
the key result of a welcome to another
episode of the kira soltanovich show I'm
excited I'm back so happy last week was
my first one back this week I have the
very funny very sweet and also uh not
what you would think mr. John Henson
he's a very funny comic host we know him
from ease talk soup from abc's wipeout
game show and also he unveils some
interesting information about himself
towards the end of course towards the
end of the podcast we had a nice chat
about his two young kids and his career
and his wives is not at the same time
not at the same time but he's a real
sweet guy and I'm so glad he came in to
sit down and chat with me and I hope you
enjoy my conversation with John Henson I
used to have a joke in my act and it
never really I guess it was too dark and
it didn't really work so Ivan but doing
it but the joke was no one in their
right mind thinks it's okay to strike a
defenseless child until you have one and
then you realize they're begging for
they really somebody needs to pull their
card can I tell you what I do the other
day um I was in the kitchen cooking i
had a like a ladle cuz I'm a Jew right
and we always just walk up ladles Britta
has nothing to do with the cooking you
know just just being armed have a ladle
yeah and my kid refused and we were
talking about this before we started the
podcast my kid refused to whatever it
was wash his hands before dinner
something that is just like a human
should do and he just kept ignoring me
and I would look him in the face and I
would say please go use the potty and
then wash your hands it's time for
dinner and he is staring at me while
like taking his lego car and just like
riding around in a circle like slowly
like a serial killer you know just
staring at me like no not going to do it
and I had the label in my right hand and
I started squeezing it and I was
standing in the doorway and so the ladle
is behind the wall he can't see but I
literally have it raised up like if he
would see me do that it would look awful
and he would say something like what are
you doing mommy that looks aggressive
Kira in the conservatory with the label
yes and I had it like raised up and
clenched nails like go use the potty and
wash your hands yeah and it felt good
just to have it knowing that I had it
raised aperture he didn't have to see it
but just having that motion of like I
could plot pummel you with this right
kind of calm me a little bit split you
can see yourself giving the explanation
of look what you made me do exactly no
to me yeah but I didn't obviously hit
him with a ladle cuz that would leave a
mark sure hi something softer evidence
ah but it just let it let me kind of
like blow off that steam yeah I am I
think you know I'm I have had this
conversation recently so my son is four
and a half when is your son's birthday
March seventh ok so wait ok I see and
and he is at that very contrary defiant
stage yeah and and I try to be a calm
parent and I try to if he's having an
issue to really like help him sort it
out you know patiently yeah but there
are times where I feel like oh no no
you're just pushing until you find the
boundary we're like it's you're not
happy with calm peaceful dad you need I
there are times where you just have to
go shock and awe and use the loud angry
voice just to let them know hey this the
the border fence is electrified right
don't touch it you know
and all the books and the articles and
the facebook posts that everybody said
it's like kindness and get down to their
level and just really namaste and calm
and take a breath but i think you're
right i don't think that they want that
well they just uh it's like I guess it's
just a human nature to just be like what
happens if I don't you know what happens
if I don't do what you ask ya know and
and just exploring the limits of their
power and independence and you know I
remember somebody telling me you know we
my wife and I my wife primarily took
some parenting classes and behind me
stuff we didn't go I mean I do but not
gonna get that part of their lives I had
it yeah exactly look I take care of you
know yeah there's heat yeah in the house
yeah right we all sit around the stoves
there's food warming our hands but they
said children like structure limitations
it they find it comforting even if
they're not aware of it even if they
push you know they they thrive on the we
go to bet we take a bath at the same
time we read books at the same time we
go to bed at the same time they'll fight
it but at the end of the day if you kind
of gave them free reign it creates a
little panic on right right they don't
know how to they don't know how to
structure their lives you have to do it
for them well I notice with my kid if we
do give him like a little like yesterday
we're living in a temporary house I
should I start with that the whoa yeah
it really sucks with a newborn our house
has water damage and we had to evacuate
I love using that word because it also
sounds like yeah crazy diarrhea my vet
had to get out and you know five weeks
old I pack up for people's lives and our
insurance company is paying for a
temporary house so we have these
neighbors and it's so great because our
neighbors now are like in their 90's or
Filipino you know what I mean like I
don't have like kids we had this
neighbors with two cute kids and so
the mom came over yesterday and she said
you guys want to come home for a little
while and I'm just about to make him
dinner but I thought I want to give him
like that fun that fun right of like
making a new friend and they're gonna
have all these new toys and I grabbed
like five Legos I grabbed like zero toys
for him so I feel really bad he's just
like bored out of his mind so we go over
there but guess what you give a kid an
inch and he takes a tantrum like he so
we go over I go we're only gonna stay
for little walks I'd have to make your
dinner and when we leave we come back
home loses his [ __ ] mind and I go I
guess we can't have fun right I guess we
can't do fun things you know I also
wanted to hang out with a new mom and a
new parent and have an adult to talk to
and he just he comes back in the house
he's totally cool chill like big man on
campus in their house walking around
like oh that's a really cool ninja
turtle car I have that one too don't
like just total he comes home loses it
now do you do cuz I I go through the
same thing with might like for instance
if I allow my kid to watch Curious
George right uh there's always a I want
to watch one more episode right so I
have to do a series of warnings yes this
is the last one you're watching Jackson
remember when five minutes were turning
this off yeah two minutes we're turning
this off no arguing one minute like and
I constantly do it and then I give him a
chance to say I go like okay say by buy
Curious George like I I have to pound it
into his brain that it's ending and hope
that he goes through like the five
stages of grief right before he actually
has that giant meltdown or should just
do what our parents stayed with my
parents just unplug the the TV when it
had just a plug got like 500 hdmi cables
but like they would just walk by my dad
would little just walk by unplug with
his foot yep just like kick it out of
the socket right go to bed right and
then yell at you if you got Elsa yeah
and that was it and then I would just oh
I guess
I guess it's over right and now we do we
do like I have like semaphore flags you
know like we have cars race I'm like all
right last lap right and by the way that
sort of implies that when we were
children we got to control what was on
the TV like I am my age I remember being
young and like spending an entire summer
watching Watergate cover you know what I
mean because it was like I didn't nobody
let me near the TV I'm like I'm like
five years old going dude this guy Nixon
is the worst but the Nixon action figure
was really cool it's all his hands about
collect all four trade with your friends
there was a button that just made him
shoot out like I am NOT a crook yeah um
I feel like so I've seen I haven't seen
it laughs factor in a while only because
I haven't been there right they just
like stop booking me well you have a
newborn oh no and by the way I'm at the
point now where like I feel like such a
[ __ ] because I have to put in my
availabilities listen I can't do sets
after ten-thirty during the week I like
if I get an eleven o'clock sediment no
yeah that's so it's like an hour past my
bedtime yeah and then they're always
running late by the second show and then
by the time I get home I'm a little
keyed up and I gotta go cuz I'm getting
up at six regardless of what time I that
my children have no respect for daddy
had a late set at the Laugh factory's
what was your other child too oh so
you're also in it like in them where
yeah we're we're in ground zero we kind
of we went with the see you space jerk
is out we went with the like it sucks
now let's just keep going yeah let's
just make it up get the diapers out of
the way yeah let's just make it a
five-year run to get through all of the
worst part of it and so we we doubled
down my brother said amigos wait when we
got pregnant second time he goes hell
what's the age difference could it be
and I go two years in a couple months
and he goes yeah that's about as long as
you need to think it's a good idea to
have another child like you need that
period of time to be like I wasn't that
bad we were so home free I mean oh yeah
sleeps he's very self-sufficient you
know he's obviously four-and-a-half he's
almost in December be five right
driving so driving as our taxes we were
really i mean we could have been chillin
right now yeah yeah you had you were
home free no we really were after after
like you're like Pacino and Godfather
they pulled me back in yeah and two is
right around like right on the corner
you'll be fine right well it's it's so
different now like the I just had this
conversation the other day so my son is
four and a half my daughter's just over
to the difference in their personalities
boy and girl and their interests and the
way they relate and the ways that they
choose to try to manipulate are so
dramatically different tell me tell me I
just of all first of all I always
believed that sexual orientation was
something you were born with but having
experienced a boy and a girl and seen
like I didn't tell my son and
exclusively by cars and trucks for him
to play with right that was just a
pre-wired like from day one that's what
he wanted and with my daughter from day
one give me a tutu give me a baby doll
you know what I mean so like when I
think of all these right-wing Christians
these are people that have a lot of kids
you can't tell me right that you can't
look at that kid and go I mean this is
not a nurturer issue if a little boy
starts gravitating and there's like a
kid in my son's class that is
gravitating towards girls toys and it's
it's just a parent so quickly uh oh so
anyway that's sort of a sidebar like I
was like it's so obvious once you've
raised kids that they just are who they
are and there's nothing you can do about
that and so nor should you want to do
anything about that so the other thing
is my daughter is so much more subtly
manipulative my son is like blunt force
trauma
I mean he's like he he'll take the what
if I scream and cry kind of you know let
me do it by force my daughter tries to
like seduce you to her way of thinking
with like batting her eyelashes and
hugging and I'm like oh you are and for
like hiring more shouting like trying to
get trying to get like you no sympathy
through pouting and it's like I just I
remember looking at her pout once my
wife was laughing and I was like I know
that pout and I know what it means for
the man she marries I can tell you right
now she is going to have that guy
wrapped around her finger do you think
she does that to you differently than to
your wife yeah yeah because I know that
my son is so different liquid tries to
manipulate with me right he does the
mummy that whole like
you know like all the times sighs yeah
yeah and with my husband it's very it's
just uh it's like dudes right
communicating right guy shut up guiseley
shut up guys emotionally guys like
communicate and primary colors like it's
just very basic yeah you know but
there's a lot more shades of gray with
my daughter who's um like you know we'll
come over and be a little sing-songy you
know but I wanna cracker and like you
know kind of like kind of sort of
smirking at me and batting her eyelashes
and and it works it works it works man
is she in like a preschool yeah but she
just started school she is sorry and
your kid is what you're at the same
school yeah so he's pre-k there this is
his last year at um but man [ __ ] two
kids in preschool my gosh [ __ ] it's like
having another house hey over 3 grand
Imam uh oh my god I mean it's nuts it's
fats crazy and we specifically moved to
studio city to get into the carpenter
school district oh yeah good public
elementary school yeah i did i just
can't [ __ ] wait to send him oh my i
don't one more year with this kid you
know come next June I'm done I'm back to
one but you probably go to one of those
like really hippie crunchy which I'm all
about cuz I can tell by the price point
trust me I have shopped right
neighborhood school in the city come on
but there's look battles and day have
you ever looked at found a all-expense
downton day in Hollywood 18 grand a year
and that doesn't include a lot of the
extras so but they have like a [ __ ] a
pool with retractable walls and ceilings
so it's indoor/outdoor their lunches are
done by whole foods like it's like a
[ __ ] college campus I send a teacher
to a toy convention every year to get
the newest greatest toys we walked in
for the tour and like it was the step
for children we walk in they're all like
two and a half year olds sitting quietly
at their desks with her
hands folded and they all turn around
and in unison go good morning parents
and I was like we got to get the [ __ ]
out of here we got to get out of here
I'm afraid these kids are gonna kill us
and you to get your kid you need to do
like an impossible thumbprint like a
retina scan yeah it's like oh whoa what
am I trying to do get launch codes here
wow I is so naive at expense 18 grand a
year they're the only preschool in the
United States that has a retractable
roof indoor/outdoor pool I wouldn't I
would love to go to this school uh Aaron
and I went to San Diego State uh-huh I
mean two decades apart but we went there
together and I think my college costs um
five hundred dollars of semester yeah
yeah and my kids preschool he's now in
TK yeah you have a kid and you start
looking into the cost of child care and
you literally start thinking maybe we'll
get lucky and our kid will be dumb maybe
maybe he's not gonna go to college maybe
he's just gonna how about a trade school
and I talked him into a trades yeah I
think that now kids can probably learn
how to uh um what's my my nephew doing
he's learning code oh yeah he's 12 sure
you just learn code I just want to be
Internet I want a kid that doesn't
aspire too much or do you want to do the
opposite and have a kid that's super
smart or athletic and they're like we
want to working for the government by
the first well yeah I mean if I could
somehow end up with a like a an Asian
baby the babies are too late I got too
late the kind of kid that's you know is
his idea of fun at seven years old is
memorizing words for the scripts
spelling bee yeah kind of thing why not
yeah I think sexual orientation they're
born that way but asian they can change
sure well yeah I got a black thing I've
got a I've got a champion my inner tiger
mom my friend told me to get my kid
tested right he's a comic his kids go to
Merman you know Merman is that genius
crazy school and have a Mulholland where
it costs five hundred dollars just to
get them tested to see if they could
and get into the school right that's
something they literally just take your
money and looking and go your kids not
yeah he's not right I can just tell from
looking at him we don't need to do the
test yeah now we can just tell by the
way pixels underwear she's wearing his
shoes on the wrong feet we're done we're
done give me your money I am my kid was
like tugging on his penis other day and
I go dude do you tease the bathroom and
he's like no I go what are you doing is
like I'm just pulling into her out of
the front where I already have a wedgie
in the front it why why what's happening
the wrong underwear you know the the
penis is I like to say fun for ages 3
and up it's that's a toy that will never
lose its luster my kid had something
going on he's like my penis hurts I go
go see daddy I don't know I don't know
yeah and my husband asked him a series
of questions that I never would have
thought of oh it only went down
checklist did you put anything in the
hole No did you hit it against something
no like I'm just go put an ice pack on
it like that's a hook tell him to do it
he will he'll put one down his pants and
walk around the house I will tell you a
very personal inappropriate stories yes
about my son's penis yes please um we
had my child circumsized animal I know
how could you mutilate your child like
that because I was mutilated and I want
him to know we we did too yeah so we uh
we we get the kid circumsized and a
couple weeks later we're at a barbecue
with a bunch of other parents that have
little boys and we're talking about
circumcision and one of the parents goes
so you have to do that thing where
you're like um like putting like
Vaseline Mike around the incision and
we're like know what what are you
[ __ ] talking about nobody and they're
like owner you gotta you have to do that
and I was like why would I touch his
dick no no we didn't know and so they're
like oh no you have to otherwise it it
like a form scar tissue and I'm like
[ __ ] so we literally like the next day
it's 905 and I got my pediatrician on
the phone from the car like I'm coming
in
clear a room I've ruined my son's dick
and and so we got it is fine he's fine
totally fine but the point is I get him
in there and this was like one of the
first appointments with my pediatrician
who's a younger woman probably in her
mid to late 30s and I'm with my wife and
she takes off my son's diaper and she
goes oh wow and I got what she goes your
son is a very well-endowed I swear to
God I swear to God and I was like god
yes I thought that I was look I
literally was like the the the legs have
to grow faster than the penises because
this ratio cannot hold up you know what
I mean and and this is giving an idea of
my wife who's also a comedian house yeah
how inappropriate not a stand-up and
improv okay any but this is how
inappropriate we are as parents the
pediatrician goes what's your son's name
and my wife goes his name's Jackson but
we call him jacks because we want to
make sure he's going to get a whole lot
of [ __ ] and I I literally like I just I
just started packing up our stuff like I
just went okay well thank you very much
like in my wife because what are you
doing we're not we're just starting the
appointment I go I don't think you can
drop the P word in a pediatricians
office and think that it's okay to stay
I'm true leaving now do you validate
like I was like we're out of here your
insurance drops you yeah um what where
is your wife what does she do I did not
know that that's so my wife Jill
Benjamin um uh is like absentia veteran
of Chicago improv um is that where you
guys met yeah we met actually she worked
for me what and we spent so much time
together at work it's interesting so I
spent months working 6 8 10 12
hours a day with her and on a show on a
project that I was producing s'okay hmm
um so the last time I was really
attracted to someone and didn't put a
move on them for four months I was
[ __ ] 14 years old like I you know
what I mean the fact that we had a work
relationship led to the development of
this chemistry and getting to know each
other normally you just sorta like jump
into bed and then you back time it and
like okay are we compatible do we like
each other really or is it just a
animalistic chemistry again Jill
Benjamin no no I'm just go yeah yeah
yeah I have to remind myself but but I
you know as I like to say it the
relationship has come full circle
because I used to tell her what to do
then we got married now she tells me
what to do so i [ __ ] my way to the
bottom yeah you did special kind of
stupid that is that's cool my husband i
also met at work really yeah yeah and i
was lower in the totem pole than him uh
and he never lets me forget it sure
feels like you were just a researcher
well and a writer researcher that got a
lifetime contract yeah I did I
lexisnexis your ass right that's a real
girlfriends that's only my LinkedIn
lexisnexis yeah that what it was called
I don't know I think it's a nexus Lexus
but yeah close enough you know what [ __ ]
I Drive a nexus Lexus 450h hybrid SUV
it's good for the kids I dare you to say
that without that protective barrier q
bueno no it's like Ziggy looking at him
you just stare you go to the nose and
then the eyes cuz you can't you can't
say it smooth your face like gold-bug
staring oh this my city my kids obsessed
with gold bug people know what that is
still Richard Scarry's book it's the
best of the best books you have a huge
one with like every vehicle yep in the
world he wanted to be gold bug for
Halloween when Frank is like take it to
back yeah um so you guys are two
performers how does that work cuz I I
mean obviously
but I dated I've dated comics I did it
actors it's always it's interesting
awful I mean we're not if she were also
a stand-up maybe it would be different
yeah but we we have like she's more of
the improv world comedic actress I'm
more of a stand-up /host so we don't
have that direct overlap in competition
yeah but we do understand enough of what
each other does that were sympathetic to
what the other person is facing in terms
of frustrations and writer why so it
kind of it kind of works but um both of
our kids are super super verbal and
we're at an extremely early age yeah and
I think it's because my wife and I just
never shut the [ __ ] up like because we
are constantly talking and doing bits
yeah so the kids like at 18 months we're
like I gotta get in this conversation
cuz I'm if I don't learn to talk now I'm
never going to get a word in edgewise I
think that's has something to do with it
absolutely my kid same same exactly the
same we one of his classmates at school
um the mom like there's like a school
facebook page where all the parents like
post stuff whatever and the mom posted
hey anybody want to go to flappers on
Saturday they do a kid show in the
afternoon i know the comic Michael
Raynor who does like a really great
juggling act he's so funny he's do you
know what I'm talking about I know
flappers but I didn't know that on
Saturday you should take your kids oh
it's so cute it's called to milk minimum
okay and it's just that's great oh it's
just full of kids and it's a great show
so I've taken Brayden a couple times and
one of the moms posted we should take
our kids and have like a and I go oh I I
and I don't tell anyone I'm a comic
unless until it comes out you know I
don't walk around going hey everybody
I'm opening for you know Brad Garrett
like I don't because and it isn't it
like you got well I'll let you finish
but i have a very specific thought about
this i don't even tell people even when
they ask why just say i'm in the
entertainment is she specially in the
[ __ ] priest great but she wrote
flappers and I was
oh well I happen to yes i work at
flappers i'm actually gonna be there
tonight right um it was their fifth
anniversary last weekend and I was like
yeah so yeah I know flappers I until you
guys want to go let me know what do you
mean you work there watch a cocktail
waitress hey the dishwasher I'm a comic
the minute I said that oh my god Braeden
is the funniest kid in the classroom
this is the first I've heard of really
Braden is all because you know when
parents pick pick up their kids my kid
goes up to them right and I know that
he's very social but I don't know what
he says to every single parent Braden
will come up to me and he'll compliment
me on my shirt and he'll say I really
liked that shirt two walks up and goes
so anybody celebrating anything to
Ronnie birthdays anniversaries anybody
got a bachelorette party you do what do
you mark what yeah but he's constantly
chat chit chattin cracking jokes um and
there was a moment where I was like oh
that's key oh no that's terrible right
like I immediately thought that's not
good right because then he's gonna be
what I was in school which was
constantly right in trouble Braden would
talk less and listen more yes great
potential that's what I always got great
potential if she just applied herself
right and by the way let's just
acknowledge that that potential thing
because I got that too is really just a
nice way of a teacher saying um like
let's hope there's potential there
because without potential your kids just
a [ __ ] idiot yeah just a blob of
cells and nerves yeah I don't know how I
feel about it I like that he's
considered like every then then I
started investigating then I started
asking around is not sure is another kit
you know and they're like oh he's
constantly doing stand-up in class
that's so he's constantly telling jokes
and write like pitching premises like
hey what if what if a cockroach and a
person had a kid would it be called a
[ __ ] person Yeah right he does beer
right and what if the [ __ ] person
went to a burger king drive through I
think it would go something yeah I don't
know why but it just cracks me up that
he does bids yeah oh my the thing that
I've noticed with preschool parents who
I we have met more people through our
preschool that we truly enjoy hanging
out with really really like these people
but what happens is I see I never tell
people that I'm a comic and even if they
do know I'm a comic I never tell people
when I'm performing no because this is
what happens and it's not it's just
human nature they go you could have told
me oh my god I'll be totally coach when
are you coming we want to come so much
do you tell us wouldn't when's your next
show you tell me and I go ah alright um
Friday night I I'm I've the eight
o'clock show at the Laugh Factory mmm
Friday night we don't have a sitter can
do that but you know what tell me next
time what are you gonna be on the next
week next week you got to tell me so now
I'm like [ __ ] so all right next week I I
got a Saturday 10pm show e dave has his
college roommate in town that weekend so
if the and now i'm [ __ ] chasing you
to come on my show which i never invited
you to in the first place it and and and
it makes me feel very and then the other
things like people are like how come you
don't tell anybody it's like guys I
don't want to take you to work like it's
you know what I mean if you tell you
when you're gonna sell insurance again
right tell me when you're gonna sell
auto you're an accountant tell me when
you're gonna do math I want to come by
and check that out are you gonna do long
division today I never tell us I save it
for really important shows right like we
did an industry night yeah and then you
want everybody and then it's like please
calm please calm please got like a you
know a show that I want to make sure you
know like if it is like for example i'm
headlining flappers for the weekend I
got four shows right I want to pack them
and by the way what about when they are
like wow I want to come and see you do a
Wednesday 1040 set when there's 18
people in the audience you have seven
minutes and it's gonna [ __ ] sock y
and
then that's going to be their impression
of you as a committee like I'm like if
you want to come and see me you come see
a sold-out weekend right I don't want
you there when I'm like going through my
notebook going what else um you know I
mean tourists from Tanzania in the front
row don't speak English right I shot um
I shot a special last month this last
Mother's Day I was um between seven and
eight months pregnant perfect cool crazy
and that's when I was like come down to
sure save your favors for when it really
counted it was Orange County oh oh we
just don't know if our mapquest goes
that far out of our zone it's out of our
friends yeah so I was like all right I
mean I and I really an errand knows I
was on I was here in this studio like
what almost every week like just
promoting like condom eyes look like 500
way to fill 500 seats and we did it was
it the improv don't know I did at the
coach house okay have you performed the
coaches know but it's noisy honky-tonk
yeah bar and these places that are I
took a gig a couple years ago on three
weeks notice so clearly somebody had
fallen out yeah giant headliner had
fallen out and it was like in the improv
and Orlando or something like that and I
was like boom yeah i mean look I'll do
him you know I'll be the guy that came
through and helped him out three weeks
notice sure I'll take it it's found
money um it's like a [ __ ] 650 °c
place and uh they hadn't done any
promotion for me so I'm like going up
for like the you know they they have
like the curtain where they cut the room
and a half right you know and then I I
want to say that there was like a
secondary curtain where they're like
maybe we need to bifurcate this audience
again let's take the cube root of our
seating because it's gone from a stadium
to like dinner theater for fourteen
people cuz you're such a non entity
that's not true but they just gave you
three weeks well yeah but it was so
he was he [ __ ] humiliating what's the
longest you've been on the road away
from I don't do I don't really do that
I'm you know a week and I I kind of um I
don't really do the road because I only
do it in town because I don't I get you
know come finally I minima four days it
got a wife and a [ __ ] house and two
kids I don't want to be at a days in nan
Atlanta for six days facetiming my kids
at dinner you know what i mean and
trying to get them to listen to me and
then like going back to compulsive
masturbation and sherry purview yeah I
mean well that's that's they expect that
the days in race any Weston yeah don't
try that no but when you go into a daisy
right now they lay down a tarp in the
room for you with the word in red roof
inn right laquinta inn right yeah they
expecting yeah the inn is in quotes um
if it is just one end yeah I have been
also the most as a week yeah and I'll be
honest I don't want to go back on the
road but do you feel like you can get an
hour like what are you I didn't want to
do in town you know it's interesting so
I just had this conversation with a
friend of mine Neal Brennan who was like
look what is your know I love Nia who
was like what is your end game cuz I um
I did stand-up for like seven eight
years and then moved out to calif is
that we in boston started out in boston
i was in college of boston and started
out there in the open mic say moved to
new york and so I got talk soup in 1995
and I moved out to LA and immediately my
schedule it was almost like we were
doing a morning show they at the time he
was covering the oj trial live from nine
to five so I had to be out of the studio
by 7am so I had to be up at like four
and at work at five come on so I was
going to bed at like eight o'clock
you know and so I moved 3,000 miles away
I didn't know the club's I didn't know
the people I didn't know the comics and
I didn't have a schedule that allowed me
relate to do stand up so I blinked my
eyes and I've been out of stand up for
like a year because that was how long
they covered the oj trial yeah and then
I became by that point I was like really
obsessed would make a television like
television seemed so new and fresh to me
and there was so much to learn and so I
kind of drifted away from stand up and I
drifted away for like 16 years I only
Apollo formed very rarely I mean very
rarely and so um people want you to
perform after seeing you on talk soup
that always seems to go hand-in-hand
like I mean I did it come do our bank
way we're giving away award occasionally
yeah and then I would like pull it
together for that yeah um but I was
lucky enough to work in television and
and and it was a in retrospect I wish I
had continued because if I had continued
touring periodically before I had a wife
and kids I'd have a great secondary
income today because I'd have a fan base
what I realized when I decided to go
back to stand up a couple two three
years ago now yeah I was like you know
what I'm gonna go i'm throwing out all
of my old material i'm starting from
scratch and just started writing and do
any of your jokes from 16 years ago
that's so weird they know like wasn't
sta ana was it wasn't the 20 year old do
you know single trying to get laid I
would help you throw away yes so nothing
worked and I started over and it was all
like marriage and kid material and and
when I got an hour I started going on
the road and I realized that just
because you're on TV doesn't mean you
can sell tickets I can be booked as a
headliner but I can't hit like my
bonuses for selling out room yeah
because you know people i mean like i
just did seven seasons on wipeouts a
show for you know i was writing
soul-crushing puns for 11 year olds
they're not coming to comedy clubs right
and and so I realized very quickly that
like the amount of money that I was
making on the road wasn't like oh man I
can't turn this down
you know what I mean and it was it just
didn't seem to be enough to justify
being away from my kids I was like I'd
rather do it in town and then try to
concentrate on like the foothold that I
have in television and keep that going
right and and I guess you know maybe
what I got to do is like do an hour-long
special and see if maybe that enables me
to sell some tickets yeah but yeah it
was sort of a rude awakening that like
just because you're on TV and just
because you can do an hour doesn't mean
oh you can go make 15 grand a weekend
selling out someplace well this is
before Twitter probably too because now
they're all about we don't care if
you're funny how many Twitter followers
do you have and I do I have like 10,000
Twitter fellow I don't have reams of ya
wit her follow yeah I'm not that's not
me I try and I'm just not it's it's not
for me I got so many [ __ ] plates I'm
spinning yeah you know ppl I look at
people who like tweet 15 times a day and
I'm like yeah you aren't wiping [ __ ] off
of another human being four times a day
are you like cuz you know we're just all
hands on deck just trying to like keep
the whole family train moving so I kind
of view twitter is like a professional
obligation but sometimes I go through
periods where I'm like I'm not really
paying attention you know what I feel
like I feel like um because it wasn't
around when I started stand-up so it
wasn't like that's why I'm you know I
know what I'm getting into here like
when I started stand-up it was go to
open mics write a lot of jokes get up on
stage right that was it and then repeat
that's it and it's almost like you know
that that that guy that works at like
IBM or hewlett-packard the company that
hey guys we got to learn a new software
or something it's like oh no i've been
doing this job i know what i'm doing i
right I I do the what is it the TPS
reports or whatever I'm office feels
like I know this is what any time
whatsoever on your GPS right yeah and
it's like no no now we got a new thing
there's a new like my mom is a fashion
designer right she's done patterns by
hand big table scissor
and you cut and you do right the the the
watchman kaulitz oh my god my brain the
patterns mm-hmm you know you do by hand
right all of a sudden in her like 60s
she has to learn how to do patterns on a
computer it's yeah she's like no no no
no no I've been doing this for 40 years
right they're like no we have a new
program right call me I pattern right
and all of your 40 years of experience
is now in haledon yes that's so that's
what I feel like right and I'm by the
way follow me on Twitter John underscore
Henson periscope in this whole thing
twitter.com John underscore Henson a
twitter com but I i I've just said
before it's sort of maddening that the
the the rise of YouTube fame and Twitter
fame has essentially destroyed the
linear progress of a career where you
start out as an open mic ER right and
you become a paid regular than a middle
ER than a headliner and then all of a
sudden you're doing theaters right and
your late-night spy exactly bridges the
gap to read your room or in that in the
world that I sort of stumbled into a TV
you know you you're hosting TV and then
you learn to write and then you learn to
produce and then executive produce and
then maybe start selling chose of you
now it's [ __ ] sixteen-year-old kid
yeah shooting dumb [ __ ] on his phone
that doesn't make any sense has 1.7
million Twitter followers and he's
selling you know advertising space at 75
grand a banner and TV doesn't have the
money to hire him anymore and it just
drives me crazy that that is now the new
direct route to fame and fortune right
after i just spent 25 years yeah
learning from the ground up bro is that
that was all unnecessary now all that
the two and a half decades that i spent
you know learning each step of the way
thoroughly before i moved on oh that's
that's useless now great yeah it's like
we're climbing Everest and then some
twelve-year-old is taking a helicopter
to right now you guys don't have to do
the walking with it is what we're doing
that freezing point trying to breathe
oxygen that isn't there you can just
to just start out right there at the top
what it's crazy I don't know if it's
good or bad because it does open up
opportunities but if one more person
tells me to start a YouTube page oh yeah
why am I gonna start a YouTube page
right I'm I'm I i just did a pilot for a
show based on viral videos working with
a company called jookin that is a viral
video as a Jukan bad enough why would
thats not yeah joint jus ken j ukin they
all they do is licensed viral videos
from all around the world they have like
teams like like you wouldn't believe
like the you remember the end of Raiders
of the Lost Ark right you know the the
place that just went on forever where
all the boxes were stored it's like that
but it's all like 22 year old kids just
surfing the web looking doing for a
living what other people get fired for
for doing at a normal job which is
goofing off online and that's they just
license these videos and so I just did a
pilot with him about launching my own
YouTube channel of viral videos and it's
I I literally feel like um my dad when
he started playing video games and was
like I got 46,000 is that good I'm like
no no it's not good I got I got like a
258 million so no 40 47,000 isn't good
dad no I feel like my mom trying to
learn how to do the running man right is
it am I doing this right I like young
hip yeah I'm like I got 10,000 Twitter
followers and like you know a the hot
intern at this jookin office is like
that's adorable yeah they get ten
thousand retweets yeah exactly yeah
exactly jus can I just see like an
application where you have to fill out
like your next of jookin in case of an
emergency yeah who's the nearest jus
right that we can contact what causes
the juke n
I i like to say that I'm fifteen percent
Jewish on my managers side are you yeah
yeah you're not no there's no Jew in you
know now is your wife Jewish know what
my first wife was oh hello yeah 34
minutes in i just talked about that i
took a mulligan what had I took a
finnigan really yeah that's my husband's
last name um what I I know what a
mulligan is yeah uh what was what was
the first marriage all about I was all
about a terrible and expensive mistake
this is I mean I don't know if you've
ever heard me say this on stage but I
always say if you want to know what it's
like to be divorced just think of the
person that you hate most in the world
and then buy them a house that's what
it's like oh my god wait a minute you
had enough money to buy someone a house
I there look at the bright side it is it
is it is not for the divorce is not for
the faint of heart you didn't have kids
with her no okay my ex-wife is about as
maternal as a Wolverine I I think
there's a greater chance that she would
eat her young then rear it yeah why
would it'd you marry her uh I was an
idiot how old were you 32 what is 26 oh
you should have known better no I'm not
for sure you're gonna be like I was in
college no crazy isn't it good bungee
jumping oh and there was a priest there
The [ __ ] and 32 we were not right for
each other but what she was totally hot
it she was smoke well you know it's like
I have a theory that when somebody goes
oh man this girl my buddies date and
this girl is completely insane I always
go she's hot she's gorgeous and somebody
and the guy goes yeah why do you said
I'm like cuz no one goes out with an
ugly psycho ha you know what i mean i
get if you heard if you hear them
describe a woman as [ __ ] crazy she's
gotta be a piece of ass yes otherwise
where's the allure there's no like oh my
god my girlfriend is a lunatic and the
hump on her back right no it's a
constant its constant taking care of
herself right there has to be like that
think also causes women to go crazy
because it's a cycle of like self-tan
manicure pedicure roots right big boobs
fake lips I let you know I brow
extension note not eyebrow extensions
that's my dad eyelash except you know
like and then it's I see them I see the
crazy women that are like super gorgeous
right yes some of them wake up that way
but most of them my ex-wife was more in
the sort of professionally driven quasi
sociopath thing I I have a black heart
oh it sounds like those were the vows is
that what she yeah yeah I promise to
love honor and take half your [ __ ] oh my
god so she's 26 yeah yeah we were
married for almost six years what and
and it cost me a whole lot of money hola
Wow me half of about half of what it
took me 20 years to save okay so I don't
know the details I don't want to know
the details that's none of my business I
mean let's do you want to tell me their
Bible no I bad and it wasn't me I I and
maybe it's just me because I do a little
bit of a hump on my back mm-hmm I cannot
imagine saying all right you want to get
divorced I want half your [ __ ] look if
there's like something amicable that
works for I don't maybe I'm just talking
out of my ass right now but I I just
could not wake up every morning just oh
stretch and be like I earned none of
this yeah like I just couldn't i would
feel like such a douche mm-hmm I just
couldn't do it I don't know and look men
do it to you know get your Federline or
whatever like whoever but but you didn't
have Britney Spears money so maybe no
but it's like unfair the person who's
always like it's only right that you
split things evenly because that's
californias that person is always the
person who doesn't have the bulk of the
money right exactly and even if I did or
didn't like I just feel like look let's
do it make sense if we're getting a
divorce but there's no reason your house
should be better than mine oh and by the
way this is a person who makes
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
and has far more job security than I do
Wow so that was one of the things that
was so [ __ ] up about it like the first
few years of wipeout for me we're
literally just making myself whole from
what I had lost in my divorce so it yeah
I mean it's it was tough but here's the
here's the silver lining of it
truthfully I mean it sounds like a
Pollyanna type Hallmark card thing to
say but if I didn't go through that I
might not have found what i have now and
and and I learned through that marriage
in the way it dissolved and how brutal
it all was what I needed in someone that
I didn't recognize when I was young and
married my first wife like it helped me
identify what I need in a partner yeah
and when I started dating my wife it was
like a revelation like it was like holy
[ __ ] you people that there are women
that will treat you like this I didn't
even know this was on the [ __ ] menu
handjobs let alone jobs in traffic let
alone now she uh oh please might the
best thing about my wife's I've got a
libido of a 16 year old yeah she does
yeah my wife will think nothing of like
putting the kids to bed coming in on a
Tuesday night shutting the door and go
and we gonna [ __ ] or what like so it's
great um but yeah it helps me it's a
pediatrician in [ __ ] it helped me it
helps me sort of like us get to where I
am today with her and my kids so she
never wanted to have kids my first wife
so it all ended up ok but you did you
did you think like oh yeah one day kids
oh yeah oh you did yeah ah I don't know
why that just is so sweet and cute to me
when guys and she would you know when we
got married she was like yeah just not
now and then that became I don't know
maybe and that became I don't wanna have
kids oh you mean the first one yeah yeah
oh but my wife and I've had that
conversation like when wouldn't people
get married and they just have never had
the conversation like when when it when
a woman gets married to a guy and she's
like well I want to have kids but
you don't want to it's like did that
didn't [ __ ] come up during the during
this should we join our lives together
however guys are hiring a band for your
wedding I want to like maybe like just
in case hey this brand x appetizers are
expensive duo kids yeah I don't know I
am I know that my husband at first
didn't but but I was like well then were
did you know then why are we together
right you know cuz I knew I go look I'm
a comic i'm very self centered because
I'm a comic and that's just what we'd
naturally are but I also know that I
want to do it all I want to have a full
well-rounded life and that sucks because
I know I probably would have a different
career if i didn't have kids sure i know
for a fact that they do which is what
this podcast is about they do [ __ ] block
my career yeah but they also give me
something else other than just me me me
me me me yeah it's a depth of experience
and your you yes something is finally
more important to you than you are right
and i think that actually makes my
career more important in a different way
so i can stead of just like me waking up
going ok me all day long i'm waking up
going oh [ __ ] the mortgage right yo it
just allows your priorities it's like an
instant chiropractic adjustment of your
priorities for me it's silenced a lot of
the white noise [ __ ] that i would
obsess about or have anxiety about that
now i'm just like i just don't have time
for that [ __ ] right like you know
comparing my career to other people's
careers or whatever it's like didn't
[ __ ] it I just gotta I gotta do what I
gotta do to take care of my family and
I'll do anything to do that so it it's
for me it's accessed a level of
diligence and and you know I die hard
need to provide for them you know if you
if you wanted to have kids does that
mean you had a pretty good childhood
because I think a lot of comics had a
shitty childhood and they like [ __ ] that
I want to repeat that yeah I had I had
to I had some pretty traumatic [ __ ]
happened to me in childhood and I I you
know I went through
this is like always a thing that people
never anticipate but I went through a
phase where I was a I had I was a pretty
bad kid for a while like I cuz you're
wearing a plaid shirt they don't know if
cuz i got but just people look at me and
i guess or a white bread i go i grew up
and you grew up in Connecticut okay got
all right stamford you know right I'll
take New York City it's not Greenwich
right next door but different place but
um yeah I got I got look it took me five
years to get through high school I got
thrown out of public high school that's
not easy to do what did you do to get
thrown out oh I didn't go to school okay
and sure and are you doing when you were
not in school I had a couple of
different businesses sort of a
grassroots sales rose a multi-level
marketing us a bathroom yeah yeah that
it started at grassroots and it moved
all the dry goods really wow yeah some
some previously owned car stereo
equipment oh I mean I just see that I
definitely don't see that I just I just
was I got into I I was a good kid but I
was pretending to be a bad kid and and
some of the people that some of the
things that I were doing were things
that were done by genuinely bad kids
right you know um and I you got the
wrong crowd yeah I just pursued that
kind of danger you know I I had
alcoholism and addiction and my family
and my parents were divorced and I it
was sort of raising myself and my
adolescence and and so I think I was
just sort of mad at the world yeah and
taken it out on anything and everything
around me and that's like in high school
primarily yeah yeah I had to repeat my
junior high school oh my god what was
that like for the other kids like hey
are you crazy man weren't you didn't you
I to leave school I to go to a private
school I had to like leave public school
you know like I they SAT me down there
like we strongly suggest
you know they basically said you're
gonna have to repeat your junior year
here but it was very clear that like
that if I stayed at the school I'd end
up just dropping out of high school
right so I they moved me to a private
school that was either for kids that had
always been in private school or kids
like me that needed more structure yeah
in their environment and I you know I
did turn it around i became i went on to
become president of that high school and
mike got a an award for service to the
to the school in the community at
graduation i gave a speech at the
graduation and stuff I got just enough
two years of good records yeah to get me
into a college that I would then avert
rly immediately drop out of to do
stand-up so switch college was at Boston
University a few years I dropped yeah so
it's a great school though um but it's
like I I have this whole I like I'm very
into um like I have tattoos people would
not normally think of me as a guy where
but um like I have a like the top half
on my back done and just tattoos I don't
say cannot even believe that but it's
but I here's what I love you like you
would turn away Latinos at a country
club you would look at you go oh he
doesn't want um any people of color at
his yacht club but um but I love
covering up all those tattoos with a
jacket and tie and impressing some
minorities because I it's like uh uh uh
you know underneath all that I gotta
look just as [ __ ] up on the outside as
I feel on the inside you know to me and
so I need to look like a subway car in
the 80s when I did these are my kids
names on my wrist those are the Ln
tattoos that you can see but but but I
it is of a deep and abiding
gratification to me when I go to like a
resort or a pool party with you know
parents for my kids preschool and I take
off my shirt and there is a moment of
like well
I have to immediately reevaluate the way
I look at you you know what I mean I hi
I didn't know you had it Ike Barinholtz
whose brilliant he's finding a good
friends with my wife and the first time
I went to a pool party with my wife's
friends and I took off my shirt I
Barinholtz goes Jesus Christ were you in
eastern promises I didn't know you were
in the Russian mafia for Christ's sake
and it was I literally looked around
like I'm I the only person here with the
tattoo but you have some like what's
that one you just show me over your
heart on my chest I have Roman numeral
for for the four people of our family my
wife and my two kids oh well some of
these are fresh new I have a I have to
tattoo appointments on the book for
October i'm going back to finish a piece
on my back a all my tattoos are family
related so but i'll show you i think i
have a picture oh that's that's what
Mexican gang members say to her la
familia um unless it's thomas the tank
or something yeah getting like you know
ms-13 tattooed on my eyelids but yeah so
this is let me see oh my gosh he should
mr. that's your back right now yeah nah
I just got done in like july so I'm
going back to have this all color
they're like when looking at like a like
a crest of lions like I am like rest and
then two lions on either side from you
are really making your dad Jim Henson
look bad right now this is not what I by
the way family if my dad were Jim Henson
my ex-wife would have made a lot more
money in that divorce but yeah so that
is safe wait let me see i got i'm
looking at your phone right now okay for
people that are listening it says father
husband I don't know why a tattoo has
never made me cry before it says father
husband brother son around my family
crest and banners yeah and then on
either side are these like sort of lions
with ISA this is all new though this
isn't like i got this when i got
transferred to that private school you
know like the families arrest in the
middle yeah I got eight years ago and
then I got it before I had kids well
then I did that um just uh my very close
with my family my brothers and I'm the
youngest of five boys oh I have a 5 / 5
on my arm for being the fifth of five
boys and and so this was our family
crest so I got that and then afterwards
I got father husband brother son put
around it and then I was like I want to
do something for my kids and I always
wanted one like I have a bunch of
smaller tattoos but I wanted one like
holy [ __ ] oh yeah yeah no I like that
its father husband it's like memento
it's like reminding you like wait a
minute do I have it's a bit like am I
should I go home be like a tombstone if
it is hit it well listen there's a good
chance i'll be dead soon but um but yeah
I mean I I think of form everybody
relates to tattoos differently I all my
tattoos are family related because I
think of them as like bookmarks to a
feeling or a motivation or a sentiment
you know when I see tattoos that
represent my brother my children or
something like that it it reminds me of
that right that depth of experience so
when you know I don't think I'm ever
going to get to a point where I go home
man what was I thinking ronning my
children with a tattoo I'm so [ __ ]
over those guys you know it's not like I
got a a you know Tasmanian devil on my
ankle when I was drunk in rolla driver
yeah my my [ __ ] fraternity you know
it's like they're things that to me I
don't grow out of you know that's why I
thought for like a split second someone
my brother passed away right so someone
was like oh you should get like a tattoo
and I was like I shouldn't like not even
for a nanosec I'm so not that yes and at
all and it's not even a pain thing it's
just it just I don't know
just doesn't just doesn't appeal to me
yeah it doesn't call to me at all but
then I see a friend of mine who has like
you know something meaningful and her
shoulder and by and I'm just like wow
you're so badass it's the I mean it
seems that way but it is it's an
aesthetic to me it really is like you
know certain people get sleeves right
now I'm not in twos I mean not I think
they look cool on other people that
doesn't appeal to me I want literally my
body to look like a steamer trunk
slapped with travel stickers just
randomly you know what I mean your next
one paraguay yeah on your exactly are
you by uh ah God that is interesting I
don't think all people would ever
picture that on your back and I like
that it's not know when other people to
die cotton oh yeah and especially coming
off of a family show and I dress like a
Republican mm-hmm but I am actually a
die-hard like hippie crunchy granola
person but I don't dress like flowy
clothes and all that you know me but I
that that's like my version of that
right people see me in there like oh you
you chop at the gap right and at j.crew
and I do but then like I'm all about you
know I'm very right comes to all the
happy stuff ya know I essential oils and
all that yeah very patchouli and all
that [ __ ] yeah I think I kind of
probably understandably look to people
like I'm very navy blue blazer you know
preppy Connecticut yuppie ish you know
yeah and all of those things right
hidden underneath underneath uh your
lettuce ah yeah exactly exactly I love
learning new things we have to wrap it
up dude I had so much fun thank you so
much I am so glad to find look I was
going to say earlier about the Laugh
Factory I knew you had kids but I'm so
happy to find out that your kids are
really young and that you are
little bit miserable like me oh really
yeah cuz some comics like yeah my kids
are in their 20s I'm like yeah I [ __ ]
other people that I went to high school
with her empty nesters now and I'm like
yeah sorry I devoted the first half of
my life to bong hits and dick jokes and
so now it is just nothing but [ __ ]
hard work and responsibility for the
rest of my life and we back loaded my
life with hard work and we learned about
[ __ ] cream get caught cream yeah you got
it yeah man you got to [ __ ] get that
[ __ ] crazy yeah don't [ __ ] up your kids
dick and then the other thing that I
never even mentioned my wife and I are
are putting a writing a book Oh
parenting oh that's gonna be sort of he
said she said perspective what's it
gonna be called you know we have some
ideas but I probably shouldn't say
anything until get it tattooed on your
back yeah I will you'll read about it on
my person we're actually gonna print the
book on me oh that's genius right that's
like a whole different book tour right
you just shove two bottles let's go say
Bartles and Jaymes barnes and nobles
right and with the marshals in jail with
the Bartles and Jaymes and you're naked
yep yep have internet pages you're just
shifting your inner thigh my yeah you're
spread and cheeks I never thought about
putting the forward on your backward yep
the binding is actually a bottle all
right this was fun yeah thank you so
much a gradual ations on the birth thank
you thank you so much I'm so by the way
so happy that you had a boy first and a
little girl I'm so happy yeah and she's
so chill it's ridiculous and chilled
mature faster than boys do so she'll
catch up yeah and you'll have your your
little boy to sort of look out for her
and protect her he's already here he
said to me the other day i was getting
them out of the car and he goes mommy
you go ahead I'll catch up it's
something I good yeah I got I got Claire
her name is Claire I got Claire you grab
her you get the groceries I got the baby
right richly and by the way I don't
[ __ ] trust my kid to pour himself a
glass of milk so I wouldn't put a lot of
stock in that I got
Claire ah he sat on her in a loving way
the other day and I was like just leave
an air hole just yeah like a snorkel of
something it's so loving that I feel bad
mhm but yeah like just by the way Lenny
and of mice and men are also mother he
loved them to death thanks for having me
Oh mr. Henson I'll see you soon in the
clubs yep hopefully before ten-thirty
yes otherwise I'm asleep alright so that
was my chat so please go follow him on
Twitter let him get 10,000 one or ten
thousand and two Twitter followers I'm
I'm kid I don't have just to listeners
but I'd like a couple dozen for the
podcast I like to self deprecated there
are a lot of you actually oh and by the
way i want to thank specifically some
twitter followers by the way at kira
comedy is mine and at kira soltanovich
is the podcast twitter handle but
specifically Peggy at peg's Gary she is
so sweet she has been tweeting where
have you been what's going on where are
you she tweeted recently a couple days
ago hands clapping and a flamenco dancer
emoticon and like a hallelujah amen my
reaction to news that at kira
soltanovich at kier comedy is back in
the studio so thanks that's so very
sweet thank you at Stewart taken at kira
soltanovich glad you're back yeah you
guys are so sweet also um who else who
else there's another one that was so
just all all up in my business um Oh to
duck feet thank you so much you guys are
just so fantastic they're just
constantly tweeting like where are you
why aren't you back where are you where
have you been so thanks and a bunch more
i'm not going to read through all them a
bunch of other people Oh act XO Katie
she wrote I'm so far behind I wish she
would have shared more about your
pregnancy alright so I didn't really I
shared a lot I didn't really hold back
on my pregnancy so yeah you're really
far behind are you listening to the
podcast from the late 80s because yeah I
didn't talk about it then because I was
I was in junior high um what else go to
our Facebook page please please please
please go to iTunes bagging you for some
reviews it just keeps us in the mix in
the loop I we just really appreciate all
the support and I am back and I'm gonna
have lots of fun new guests and and
support everybody here at the All Things
comedy that's the twitter handle also at
all things comedy better podcast hooks
are so many and they're also great and
are also funny and keep supporting us
things see you next time